it's lovely to have you here today but
there is a reason why you're here and
maybe now is a good time to tell the
audience absolutely yes so we are
announcing a collaboration between
Lucasfilm and ILM xlab and magically
we're building a collaborative
laboratory right in San Francisco right
adjacent to our offices where X lab
works where we'll be able to work and
create and co invent some of the
technology and of course the content and
the creative that's going to go into
powering the future so this is an
exciting announcement something that's
been more than a year in development as
we've gotten to know each other I've
done a bunch of experiments together and
now we're taking it up a level and
letting the world know what's going on
kind of in the secret lab yeah what's
what's really cool about it is the the
combined team there has an amazing
universe almost infinite storytelling
capability and it really starts with
story
kind of like wouldnt it be cool if and
then the Lucas guys say well let's build
a little story around it and we've been
testing these experiencial story moments
and trying to make mix reality not a
novelty but a way filmmakers and and
others can actually create real
experiences and things that you know
elevate and add to the universe of
something like stuff exactly and the the
the makeup of X lab is the strongest
parts of our company it's a it's the
story group that the same story group
that's writing the stories that are
you're going to see in cinema across the
next decade and it's the de firepower of
ILM Zardi at very advanced graphics and
other sort of methodologies that are
emerging and it's at Skywalker Sound
which has been the leading edge of
making sound scapes and and defining
universes through sound so those three
components are actually what X lab is
but at its center it's about the story
experience and where that goes we
understand that these emerging platforms
are about experience it's about your
experience it's about placing you in a
universe and having story how
around you and to you so it's really a
different it's a different form that
we're going to be exploring in this lab